hmmm what's up you bad [__]
let's clean out the old Paris from the
[__] old pipe here
whatever I smoked this morning I've been
smoking in token since 6:30 this morning
like a [__] Savage wait for you
[__] but now we herewith we okay
it's time to get this party started
where's the Hondurans at I've been over
here waiting for 10 days for these
[__] don't walk up here like
Lewis and Clark and nobody showed up
any day now I'm expecting to see a
[__] thousand people with tap-dancing
shoes on and [__] sore feet and
whatnot but who gives a [__] it's
Tuesday November 14th the day the devil
was buried at sea the is sling and dick
or you're not you understand me the rest
is up to you uncle Joey here with some
tremendous [__] weeds today we got
the OG Kush from Zeki we got the [__]
dosey doe from Zeke
we got this [__] afterglow
little put hair on your [__] chest
you know I'm saying but you know me I
always show up with nothing but [__]
gems of debt gotta give me the full
[__] patois hey guys all again like
the side you gotta get full anyway you
bad [__] his Apple uncle Joey
haven't seen you in a while [__]
podcast is up to the Brody podcast at
the old podcaster Felicia podcast if you
came to the shows in New York you're bad
[__] you were savages and
that's it and that's that offending a
little nip name with him today but the
sun's on that side once the Sun gets on
this side I'll be [__] shirtless you
know I'm sayin like [__] both Christ
you're on a Friday night
but 10:15 BISM anyway
a happy Veterans Day you know I love
your [__] with all my heart I
didn't have the balls to [__] join
the army because I couldn't go for a
blood test so I got nothing but respect
for you [__] veterans Rene and
cost y'all the captain of the Church of
veterans if you've got any questions
that PTSD shooting Puerto Ricans Rene
I'll help you the [__] out beside that
Joey what's with the [__] any of beaten
we're gonna spark here or one let's
[__] spark it's been a while I got
the savage look at this [__] he
look like he's finished eating cake
Quigley's [__] looking anyway that's a
joke peep all right don't take it -
[__] cereal please so I got a bunch
of [__] women out here with marches
and sticks jumping up and down I need
that like I need a whole head I also
want to send my heart out to the people
in the [__] fires it's just you know
a few [__] Mouse man it's it's it's
it's it's hard to imagine people value
evacuating you gotta leave your house
and [__] it is what it is God gives us
different problems every day you know
I'm saying no matter what what part of
your life you're and you gotta struggle
every day so don't think because well
God's got it out for me so no no no
nobody's got it out for you
it's just a struggle and every day you
got to overcome a different thing I woke
up to my favorite cat being [__] sick
it's on the way to the vet right now
listen this is what life is all about
not every day's a bowl of cherries or
not it wouldn't be [__] life so it's
not you you don't need to go talk to a
psychiatrist life his wife and they
throw a curve ball at you from time to
time
you know you do you look in the mirror
you throw some water in your face you
take a deep breath and you go I'm in I'm
gonna handle this like a [__] savage
that I am if not you lose your [__]
mind
you understand me you gotta keep control
it's gotta be a yeah and a [__] yeah
Joey which what the it beatin that
[__] weed is a putting uh who gave you
a line of coke and got you started on a
Tuesday morning you know who me
[__] cuz that's what I do I
fire myself up I don't give a [__]
I don't get my [__] about what anybody
thinks if I made it this long
[__] it we're going deeper now
tremendous switching it up now to the og
cush because you [__] know how
we do it look at that nice nicely nice
we fill it up to the top here I'm saying
if you want to take an ounce off with
cream you do that on your own [__]
time this ain't [__] Starbucks
this is Uncle Joe we fill these [__]
pipes to the pipe can't take it you
should live look at his face now anyway
it's a beautiful day to be alive
[__] that's the first thing
that should come out of your mouth it's
a beautiful day to be alive whatever you
might get hit by a train tents or flying
[__] my hit you in the face and you'll
be lookin that thing like a [__]
thirsty dog that just ate a hot dog you
follow me this [__] so get me she is
itchy
that's when you know some [__] reef is
[__] on fire but anyway you know I
love you I got your back
listen if anybody comes clean it's me
I've been slipping with the [__]
periscopes but the next two weeks I'm
home I got meetings I got [__] you know
but our fits are men from time to time
to let you know the holiday season's
come and if we're family this is when we
really [__] connect during our holiday
seasons there's a lot of years are gonna
be down but Uncle Joe is here never fear
with the Cape a big dick toothpicks and
[__] heart control blood pressure
medication anyway I got a show next
Friday night 9:45 at the improv it's the
Late Show the day after Thanksgiving you
[__] are ready to go y'all turn
it up
you slept from all the tryptophan and
you're ready to stab a [__] who
shows up your uncle joy but it'll all
start line up down there that's gonna be
a great [__] night nine four
five at the MPM you know why cuz I'll
[__] around I don't give a [__] I
enjoyed it I Kate I got some sir don't
worry about nothing just show up 9:45 at
The Improv Friday night the 23rd of
November oh I love to smell a reef in
the morning understand me all you need
now is to sniff somebody's ass holes and
you're ready to go to work the smile on
your face people like why you so happy
you have no [__] idea
now we're gonna smoke some of this
[__] what we got left we got this
[__] og cush what the dosey doe and
then we got the [__] and I have to glow
this is going to dog [__] you get the
same result from smoking this is jumping
in the Hudson you glow in the dark like
four [__] days and I sit and that's
that you know I'm saying that the
beautiful day to be alive I know you got
struggles like everybody got struggles
all right everybody got struggles you're
not [__] special
get your [__] balls Tucker men grab
them and go who the [__] is gonna stop
me today I ask myself the same question
every day I wake up my mom a little BOTS
a cup of coffee but then you grab your
balls you know who the [__] is gonna
stop me today we got the [__] who's
got the [__] are you kidding me the
Koreans with 20 missiles can't stop the
Cuban you follow me
I'm speaking of Korean that poor [__]
career in this army that [__]
mung bean burritos no more that little
guy here got him with that little
Mexican elbow let me taste him
my little Mexican elbow was invented 20
years ago those Mexicans got some sharp
[__] elbows you follow me they don't
[__] around that yeah you bent over like
the bar like the judge like a [__] like
he was serving your twice cooked pork at
the Chinese restaurant and they came up
with that little elbow that [__]
Korean Zombie he's done you're gonna see
him on The Walking Dead next week
walking around with a [__] bullet
hole his [__] eyebrow anyway my
shout-out today I hear he's a bad
[__] ko yeah okay we're on mahek
I'm outside of it boy a little app you
don't get the wrong color pig noise
laughs what's up at that moon boo
anyway I smoked this refund let's start
our day let's inflict ourselves on this
[__] understand me is good people if
you can't win them over with a right
hook you win a mobile with personality
and spots down and that don't work a
finger in the ass always gets me from
safety
if I take stone you wouldn't believe me
but I am I'm a good time with your piss
yeah here with that [__] Out Boy
those elbows good those Mexicans jump
that wall they put that first elbow over
and they pulled themselves up that's
[__] strength right there you get one
of those Mexican elbows so low but the
[__] champ
I know Mexican that fell off a roof one
day didn't go to emergency room those
guys are tougher than [__] and shoe
mother oh yeah okay we're gonna make a
dough I don't know what happened to the
Saint day fox but anyway who the [__]
my political [__] genius
what is this CNN news this is uncle Joey
[__] TV [__] and where I'm
live on a Tuesday morning that's when we
show up when uncle Joey really needs you
anybody could show up on a Monday and
give you fake news and I'm saying uncle
Joey's got a Tuesday smoking reef is
using [__] kebab sticks is [__]
well you know what's crazy we still got
a boat left this in my world you don't
walk on one leg it says you gotta get
down [__] so if you haven't practiced a
Mexican elbow you better start
practicing it right now the Korean
Zombie guy had idea dad ask him if he
wants to talk up you don't want to see
[__] nothing he won't even see the
[__] movie Coco no more it's over
[__] a Korean zombie nothing that's
Korean people you know I love you
[__]
[Music]
all right that's it that's that the
podcast is up you're ready to rock your
nine days away from Thanksgiving from
that sitting that's not a classic
holiday season and we get together
that's when we really bummed as a family
because hey I'm with you you're with me
and these little [__] [__]
want to be with us you understand me
we're swinging dick we're not sitting
there now waiting for the [__]
Bluebird of happiness we're going out
and we're not gonna Boober to happiness
out I'm taking this little [__] pink
person anyway I love your [__]
see you Friday night The Improv Irvine
9:45 show you better have 20 edibles
we're gonna have a dog [__] we're
gonna have a dog at the door we don't
kill the dog you're not allowed and you
understand me stay back
I love you [__]